that is what a arm a communication
system is how can we understand these
communication systems a little bit and
for that I'd like you to turn to this
diagram that's embarrassing
I want you turn to this diagram which is
at the bottom of the news post let me
zoom out a little bit okay and let's
talk about what a communication system
is so this this diagram is called the
communication system framework it's
right out of the syllabus so I didn't
make it up though I think I did pick
these clip parts anyway so you do need
to know this is really important the
good thing is it's quite simple I think
it's quite easy to pick up you have a
three layers to it as you can see we're
gonna spend our later lessons digging
into what each of these eleven layers
mean for instance you might look at this
and think I have no idea what that's
referring to and there's a good reason
for that here's the first important
thing that I want you to get about this
diagram okay this framework the
application there look you see that this
is the one where we see it okay this is
the only level that most of us should
actually perceive when we work with
communication systems okay so example
you're on Facebook right and chat window
comes up and you're typing a message to
a friend so you're interacting with an
application there strictly speaking
you're interacting with two you're
interacting with your browser and you're
interacting with Facebook okay go to
applications you can see them you're
you're typing into them right if someone
said to you hey what are you using right
now you might say I'm using Chrome and
I'm using Facebook these are
applications you can see okay in the
same way the messages destination the
person's going to can also see the same
applications maybe they're on their
phone right so they're using Safari
something like that okay but the
applications they can see it so the
users and participants are up here and
this is whoops this is alway meant to
really be able to see at least if the
system is doing its job however
underneath the surface right so a
picture like an iceberg
right all of this stuff is happening to
ensure that this actually works properly
okay
so what's happening in here
communication control and addressing we
won't go into detail but all I want to
get across to you is this level is about
the software that's underneath these
applications okay this is a software
level mainly so things like when you go
to Facebook right um the dress of
Facebook is not just facebook.com it's
um HTTP colon slash slash facebook.com
right what's all that HTTP business well
it's to do with all this extra software
right which makes sure that these
applications can work so this software
in here which you can't see we'll talk
more about those a bit later on and then
further under that there's what we call
a transmission level you might also call
it the hardware level okay so if you
like you've got three levels here not
just these names but an easy way to
remember is people software and hardware
okay it's not the best way to understand
it because actually there is some
hardware in this level and actually
there is some software in this level
okay but it's sort of a rough basic way
to understand that transmission level
gets the stuff that you can hold with
your hands that you could touch and put
your fingers out okay so stuff like your
modem stuff like saying the antenna in
your phone all of the towers that are
out there which provide reception all
the wires that go underneath the ground
and I'm along the sea floor which
provide us with Internet connectivity
okay these are all the transmitters and
receivers that we're talking about
hardware now just this last bit I want
to refer to switching and routing what's
switching and routing routing or taking
your route right is about the path to
get from one place to another okay so
just like this is convenient not
entirely on purpose
when you go in a car from one place to
another
okay if your journey is anywhere longer
than say five minutes at least on sydney
roads there's got to be multiple ways to
get there
right some ways you can take the main
road sometimes you get back streets
sometimes you can take lots of different
back streets or different main roads and
you've got all these different ways that
you can navigate through it right in the
same way when data goes from mm-hmm a
sender a source to a receiver to its
destination
okay there's lots of different ways to
go and that's what this process
switching and routing is talking about
okay when we talk about A to B that's
very simplified okay just like when
you're really traveling on the internet
there are many different ways to go now
I've sort of glossed over this idea of a
medium because we've talked about it
before medium just means in between
that's why we have small and large and
the in-between size we call medium right
so medium is whatever is in between all
of these paths so for example the wires
right all the wireless link okay that's
the medium right right now the medium
between us is the air right the way I'm
the source and communicating to you is
my transmitter which is what's the
hardware that I'm using right now it's
long as my mouth my mouth is actually
not doing really the work the brain is
involved I think is probably closer to
here which actually composes the message
and creates it yeah well in my throat
there are these two guys called my vocal
cords right and and do this weird thing
which physically transmits a signal it
vibrates the air right and it goes
through the medium of the air switching
routing not so much shape is quite
direct right but it arrives in your
receiver right which is which is be
specific I'm trying to talk to you right
but what's the physical hardware thing
it's a it's a bone in your er right
which receives the vibrations in the air
that I'm sending out
and they get to your brain eventually
and that's what's going on okay so this
framework works for any communication
systems where it's hard whether it's
electronic or non electronic like I'm
talking about now okay